- Hi, everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to the homeroom live stream
we have a very exciting show.
I guess you could call this a show today
where we're gonna announce
the 2020 Breakthrough
Junior Challenge winner.
But before we jump into that,
I will give my standard
announcements reminder
that we are not for profit.
We can only exist through donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate.
I also wanna give a special shout out
to several corporations
that have helped us over the years,
but especially during COVID,
as we were already running at a deficit,
our deficit only increased as more
and more folks have become
dependent on Khan Academy.
So special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly and Novartis.
And it has helped, but we still
have a gap especially for 2021
and many millions of dollars of gaps.
If you wanna continue
to have tens of millions
or hundreds of millions
of folks being able
to keep accessing their
potential, please think
about making a donation if you
are in a position to do so.
Last announcement, there's a version
of this live stream that
you can get as a podcast,
wherever you typically get your podcasts.
If you go to homeroom
with Sal the podcast.
And with that, I am excited to introduce
our first guest who is
not the surprise guest,
but then she will help me introduce
the surprise guest, Hillary Andales!
Hillary, thanks for joining, Hillary
is the 2017 winner
of the Breakthrough Junior
Challenge, welcome Hillary.
- Hi Sal, it's really amazing
to be here I'm really honored.
- No well, I still remember
I'm one of the judges
and I still remember fondly
your entry two to three years ago.
Well, you know, I am curious
before we introduce this year's winner,
what made you try to win
the Breakthrough Junior Challenge?
What was kind of your mindset into it
and how has it affected
your life since then?
- Yeah so I actually joined
it the first time when I
was in 11th grade in 2016.
So that's four years ago
and I just, for me, it was a huge gamble
'cause I knew the
Breakthrough Junior Challenge
was a large competition right?
And so I was at first really intimidated
'cause if this is international,
then I'm gonna be competing up against
all these other really
smart high school kids
from all over the world.
But I just went through it anyway,
cause like, I always say this have
this mindset that if you fail,
you never really fail, you only learn.
And so I carried that mindset with me
so I tried that the first time
and I ended up getting the special prize
that year the popular vote.
And then I tried again the next year.
It was my very last try
cause I was already 18 at that time.
So I was like, okay, I
need to put everything
into this entry, I need to invest
a lot of effort into it
and so it really just, I
guess it all worked out
and I did win that year
and this competition
has actually changed my life so much.
I mean and even until
now four years later,
I feel like it's the gift
that keeps on giving.
It just, it has led me to MIT,
it has led me to Science Communication,
it has led me to reach so many people
all around the Philippines in the world
and it's just really
changed my life so much.
And I'm certain that it could be
the same kind of change
for this year's winner
and I'm really excited to see
how it pans out for them as well.
- No and I think what's
really powerful about
it is just the experience of doing it
and producing the videos
and it doesn't just take deep
insight in math or Science.
It takes great communication
skills, great creativity.
I think the winners are, you know,
I tend to give extra points in my head
for the folks that can
make me laugh a little bit.
- Yeah.
- And you were definitely one...
So yeah, there's a lot
of really cool skills
that come into this together.
Well I have more questions,
but I think it would be fun to ask you
and the new winner so maybe
we can announce this together.
So this year's winner for her video
on quantum tunneling, Maryam
Tsegaye and she's here.
- Hey.
- Hi Maryam congratulations.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Maryam, congratulations, I
have so many questions for you.
I guess both myself and
Hillary have questions.
Although I have questions for both of you,
but I guess first of all, Maryam,
what does it feel like to win?
- Absolutely crazy it's just unreal,
I'm still absorbing I don't know.
It's just, nothing's going
to be the same from now on
and I'm just waiting and
I'm on my ride, yeah.
- Well, before I dig deeper,
'cause I have a ton of questions actually,
for both you and Hillary, I think
it's worth everyone taking
a look at Maryam's entry.
And learn a little bit
about quantum tunneling.
- So I was watching my
brother play this video game
and he used a cheat code
that let his character do
a walk through walls hack.
He pushed himself against a barrier
in the game, hit some buttons and boom,
his character appeared on the other side.
Imagine if he could walk
through walls in real life.
And it turns out you
can at a quantum level.
We're talking on a scale of the stuff
that make up atoms, strange things happen
at a quantum level.
For one thing, all subatomic particles,
they've got split personalities.
One personality is a wave and
the other one's a particle,
but there's still one being.
When you wanna know where they are,
they seem like a particle.
And when you wanna know
what they're doing,
they behave like waves,
but you can't ask both
personalities at the same time.
Basically they've got some
serious commitment issues
and that means we can only
guess where they might be.
Imagine an electron has
to dice, six sides each
what the electron rolls
is where it will sit along the line.
Our electron can't commit
to a position until the dicer rolled.
Remember there's commitment issues.
So as our electronics shaking the dice,
it's everywhere at once.
Something like us trying
to measure its position,
has to force the electron
to let go of the dice and pick a spot.
Of all combinations getting a seven
is more likely than two or 12.
In reality, though, the electron
can be in more than just 10 spots
since there are many more
combinations than just two dice.
Now we can pick your subatomic protocols
as this, a probability wave.
This wave will tell us the odds
of finding a particle at that location.
Say, this is our electrons
probability wave.
The peaks of the wave is
where we're most likely
to find the electron and in the valleys,
it's less likely you'll find it there.
Let's say the electron is
heading towards a barrier,
as it hits the barrier,
the wave, it bounces off.
But let me tell you something about waves.
They are not perfect.
For example, a beam of light
doesn't perfectly reflect
off of the surface.
A small fraction of light can get through.
Waves won't bounce off perfectly
so neither will the electron wave.
Sometimes the wave can
slip through the barrier.
When the wave is in the barrier,
the chances of finding
an electron there goes down by a lot.
But if the barrier's thin enough,
the wave you can reach the
other side before it dies off.
So what does that mean?
Remember the wave tells us how likely
it is to find the electron there.
This means there's a chance
we can find our electron
on the other side of the
barrier or in there too.
Once it's on the other side,
we can say the electron
tunneled through the barrier.
This is quantum tunneling
and that's how subatomic particles
can walk through walls.
Okay, so little elementary
particles can walk through walls,
but I can't because my
body's made up of more
than a quadrillion of
these quantum objects
and the odds of all of them tunneling
through the wall is
practically impossible.
So why does quantum tumbling even matter?
It's the reason we're alive.
(giggling)
Quantum tunneling allows nuclear fusion,
sounds familiar?
That's how our sun releases huge amounts
of energy that makes life
on our planet possible.
So how can you quantum tunnel at home?
You already are.
It's one of the ways our DNA mutates among
other worlds that quantum
Physics plays in our Biology.
Quantum Physics makes it seem like
the world is playing cheat
codes on us, but it isn't.
It's how the Universe works.
Maybe the quantum world is telling us
that when faced with an obstacle,
there's a small chance
we can defy expectations
and breach barriers.
(piano music)
(laughing)
- I watched it, obviously as
a judge and really enjoyed it.
But I now see a metaphor
between quantum tunneling
and winning the Breakthrough
Junior Challenge.
Both of you all have quantum tunneled.
- Yes.
- Maryam, let me ask you,
why did you pick quantum tunneling
and what were you thinking
as you went through the process?
- I didn't know what quantum tunneling was
at first I thought I was gonna
make my video on entropy,
but I was watching a video about entropy
and it was talking about
the universe reaches its maximum entropy
like quantum tunneling will happen
and the universe will restart
and it was like, wait, what, wait,
what is quantum tunneling?
What do you mean the universe will start?
And I searched it up and I was like,
how have I never heard about this?
Because there's a lot of
like quantum phenomena
that you hear about,
but I've never heard of quantum tunneling.
And I just kind of went down
a rabbit full of articles and stuff.
And I just thought I can tell
a story better than entropy.
So I went with that.
- And I'm curious for
both of y'all I mean,
we start with Maryam and then Hillary
have y'all done videos before
have y'all done anything like this before?
This was just kind of on
a whim you said lemme yeah
Let me have a shot of that, Maryam?
- Yeah like at school we do have
like project-based learning things.
So like once you learn something
you might like make a video
about it or something.
We've definitely had video projects before
and I've made a few videos for the class.
- What about you Hillary?
- Well, for me, I definitely
had zero experience.
That's why at first I was really hesitant
to join the challenge
cause it was making videos,
but I actually had experience
in making graphics graphic design
'cause I used to make fan art
for the show called doctor
who I was so obsessed
that I just had to make fan art.
And that was when I
learned that the skills
like visual so that's how I started.
- Very cool you know, we
have another fun video,
this is an excerpt of Hilary's video
from a couple of years ago,
which is also a very...
I thought I fully understood
relativity before I watched it,
but there's a couple of good
metaphors of visualizations you
have there that, that were
like, oh yeah, that's,
that's a really cool way of
thinking about it and actually
on the quantum tunneling side as well.
But you know, there's a fun video
that myself and Scott Kelly recorded
to surprise Maryam and believe me,
if you could show the video
of Maryam finding out about her winning.
I believe that the video
creators' name was Maryam.
One of the things that I
think we can do together
as two of the judges
have helped many others
is maybe to speak directly to Maryam.
And you know, I just
wanna let you know Maryam,
you are the winner-
- Oh my God!
- Of this years'
breakthrough youth challenge
250,000 dollar scholarship,
100,000 dollars Science
lab for your school,
50,000 dollars for your teacher.
They are yours, congratulations.
(sobbing)
- Tell us what was going
on in your head, Maryam,
when that was happening.
- I think my head just froze.
(chuckling)
there wasn't like there was
no processing or anything.
It was just like disbelief and shock.
I didn't think-
- And
- Yeah, no, I didn't think
when I walked in to that room,
I was told something completely different
and I just didn't think
anything was going to happen.
- What did they tell you
what's going to happen?
Why were y'all there?
And it looks like y'all
were in a socially distance classroom.
What was going on?
- Yeah, so we were told that
we were coming to school.
It was a Friday where
we didn't have school
and we were just told like, oh yeah,
you're gonna film like
this grade six video,
like to advertise our school
for sixth graders in town to come.
And I'm there like, oh, actually first.
Alberta education wanted to like film
some stock footage of kids, like reacting
to a certain video
and my principal Mr.Barr,
he was just like oh it's just, I picked
this podcast for you guys to react to.
And I was like, okay.
And just completely dismissing
all the clues that were
happening oh how come?
Okay oh, there's a
filming crew oh whatever.
Oh, it's not Kelly its nothing.
All there talking about is
the Youth Junior Challenge
It just never, I don't know.
- That's good so you have a healthy amount
of naivete about you,
which made the surprise.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- Which means that
you're easy to surprise,
which is always a good thing in life.
Well, Hillary, you're getting,
to talk a little bit about this,
but I'd love you to kind of tell Maryam
what the world has in store for her,
how have you used the scholarship money?
What happened with the lab money?
What does your teacher
done, with the money?
- Yeah so I mean, your life
is never gonna be the same after this.
And right when I think
that I could finally
move on for the Breakthrough
Junior Challenge,
I keep getting new, cool
things, new opportunities
because of the stuff that I did
with the Breakthrough Junior Challenge.
So it's really amazing.
And I mean, of course it led me to college
here at MIT it's fully free
and it's really amazing to go to school
without having to think
about money at all.
And so I feel really grateful for that.
And now that you have that scholarship,
you will have that kind of freedom also
to pursue your own
interests without worrying
so much about money so
that's always great.
And you will also have
so many opportunities
to meet cool people.
I mean, just that the awarding ceremony,
I don't know how that's gonna work
this year 'cause I mean the pandemic
but you will meet so many cool people
and in college you're going
to meet even cooler professors
and then you might even, I don't know,
consider doing Science
Communication from now on
'cause you're really good
at explaining things.
So that's like you haven't asked her that.
And for me, I kind of capitalize on that
after the Breakthrough Junior Challenge.
Before the challenge, I was only thinking
about doing pure Astrophysics,
but now I'm also considering
Science Communication
and like broader impacts as well.
So that life is never going
to be the same from now on.
- I'm curious, Maryam, what
are you thinking about doing?
You are you are a senior,
so you are applying to college right now?
- Yeah, I am a senior.
I'm not entirely sure I know I want
to major in Physics
and hopefully some kind of program
that does have like a more
interdisciplinary approach
to Science and Physics.
But I know I will like in the future
or actually now, from now on, want
to do Science Communication.
I've always admired Science Communication.
- Yeah well I think both
of y'all could do both.
I always feel that if you
really understand something,
you should be able to explain it
or if you explain it, you
should be able to understand it.
So I think they go hand
in hand, it's funny,
sometimes when I'm doing research
for something on Khan Academy,
I'll call a friend, who's
an expert in the field.
And I was like, yeah, I have this really,
what I think is probably a dumb question.
Why does A need to be in there?
Like that's actually a
fundamental question no one knows.
I was like, oh wow,
(chuckling)
I've touched on an area of research
and I have no doubt that both of y'all
are gonna do incredible things.
And I actually, I have so many questions
for both Myriam and Hillary
remind everyone watching
put questions on YouTube and Facebook,
I'm going to surface as
many of those questions
as possible to Maryam and Hillary.
Maryam I got to say, I
don't think you're gonna
have any trouble getting into college.
I'm assuming your grades
and test scores are decent.
(laughing) If you need a tutor let me know
although I don't think you do.
And-
- I mean technically
you are my tutor for me.
- Yes I mean, not, to
be shameless about it,
but both of y'all do psych Khan Academy
is playing some role in your lives
I don't wanna toot our
horn too much, but...
(laughing)
And I'll also say the part
that event that Hillary has referred
to is normally it's in November.
Because of COVID, I
think they're gonna delay
it to March or whenever,
but they're still gonna do it.
And I have to say it is the fanciest party
that I go to every year, I bought a tuxedo
just for that party.
It's the only time in the
year that I wear a tuxedo
and I go hungry because
the food is really good.
So I look forward to hopefully
seeing you all there.
- Hopefully.
- So let's see there's a
bunch of questions here.
Let's see I mean, there's
one from Facebook,
which it feels like just compliment,
which is always good to receive.
Peter Mastriani says outstanding,
wonderful communicator.
Kudos makes an extremely complicated
and otherwise seemingly
impossible challenge,
challenging concept, understandable.
You will inspire and open minds
with your work applause.
So people are loving
and I think that's both of y'all's work
has kind of met that bar.
You know, SmartBear five
from YouTube, Hillary
and Maryam what are your future plans?
You've you've touched on it a little bit.
I mean, maybe I'll
start with you, Hillary.
Hillary, are you a Physics major
or what are you majoring in?
- Yeah, currently I'm a
Physics major here at MIT.
I also do research
and during the weekends I
also do Science Communication
talks in the Philippines.
So I'm kind of been doing
both hand-in-hand so.
- Oh, wow so where are you right now?
Are you distance learning
from the Philippines
or are you in Cambridge?
- I'm been MIT actually I'm on campus.
- Okay, oh very cool.
And what do think you're gonna do?
I know still, what are you,
you're a sophomore Junior?
- Yeah I'm a sophomore right now
and right now the plan
is to maybe pursue a PhD.
So that's the plan right now AstroPhysics.
I'm really interested in that
and also do a lot of Science
Communication on the side.
I found that I really get excited
when I talk to people about Science
and I feel like it's really something
that I wanna pursue in the longterm.
So I'm not sure what kind,
what form Science Communication.
I mean, you can be very creative
with how you pursue that line of work.
So I'll figure that out,
but for now, I'm just gonna
keep on doing what I'm doing.
That is talks and doing problem
sets in my Physics major.
- Very cool well, you know,
going to get your PhD,
you will make my mother proud.
She still, asks me questions,
whether I could get like
some credit towards a MD
or a PhD through my Khan Academy work.
And Maryam what about your,
I mean, I know your earlier
you said you might be a Physics major,
are you thinking kind of a similar track
to what Hillary is thinking of?
- Yeah I know that I'd
liked to pursue Research
and like Physics and Science and all that
and more like interdisciplinary things.
I don't know I don't like, set categories
all the time for different things
and definitely Science Communication
because yeah the world as a
whole needs to work on that.
- Well, I know an organization
that could use the benefit of people
who know how to make good Science videos.
So I'll, see if I can, connect you
to some people who have influence there.
So we should, we should talk about that.
Let's see other questions here
someone I see Facebook, Retta Gray
and says, what is the
most beautiful moment
in your Breakthrough Junior Challenge?
I guess you could interpret
that question however you see fit.
Was it the moment you found out about it?
Was it the creation?
Was it telling your parents?
was it telling your teacher
that they're getting 50,000 dollars?
I mean I didn't talk about
the price is 250,000 dollar scholarship,
100,000 dollar lab for your school,
50,000 dollars for the teacher.
And then obviously you get
to go to this great event
and meet movie stars
and a couple of nonprofit directors
who have their tuxedo that
they wear for that day.
(chuckling)
What has been y'all best moments so far?
I don't know let's start with you Myriam
and then Hillary you've
had more of the moments,
but Maryam what's been
really standing out?
- I think the first moments where like,
the creation of the video,
I was like, I didn't know
what I wanted to do and
the deadlines coming close.
So I was like, okay, I
need to decide on my topic.
And I knew, the part of me wants
to do quantum tunneling
so I went out on a walk
and I babbled to myself a lot
and I was talking to myself,
people would've been staring at me,
but then I was like, oh my goodness.
I think I can explain the
Heisenberg Uncertainty Principle
and like all these things
with split personalities and whatnot.
And the video was like forming in my head.
And I was imagining it as I was walking.
And I was like, oh my goodness.
I was taking out my
phone every five seconds
and like writing something
in notes so I won't forget.
And I was, this is gonna work,
I can't wait to, explain it like this
and show people that you
don't need fancy equations
to understand Quantum Tunneling
and Schrodinger's wave
function and all that.
And same with, it was
mostly the explanations
and stuff, like coming
up with the script thing.
That was like the whole time
I was in the state of flow.
And yeah, when the whole dice
analogy was like another,
I guess a light bulb moment for me.
And yeah, that was like,
I was really excited
to like, get the video all together.
- You know, ever since seeing your video,
I've been quoting you a few times.
Every time someone mentions
electron, I go, you know,
they have commitment issues.
(laughing)
- That's how I saw it.
- Hillary what about you?
what are the moments that
have really stuck out for you?
- Yeah, for me, I mean,
yeah, as you said earlier,
I've had more of those moments
'cause it's been a while.
But one thing that stuck out
to me was my acceptance speech,
it was a really nerve wracking moment.
I wrote my acceptance
speech on the plane ride
on the way to California.
So I really poured my heart out for
that really short acceptance speech.
And I was really happy that I got
to say that in front of the world
and it was a live
streamed and all of that.
And it was a really amazing moment for me.
It's like winning the Oscars,
but in Science and for
high school students.
So that was really for me.
And another thing that stuck
out to me was when I talked to
a bunch of elementary school
kids in the Philippines.
So I had gotten invited to that event.
It was a very impromptive event.
And one of the organizers of that heard
that I had won the challenge
and they invited me to
talk to all these kids.
They were really tiny and
they were fourth grade
or sixth grade and they
were also energetic.
And I talked to them
about Science and about
the Hubble space telescope
and all of these cool things.
And they were just so energetic
they had so many questions
and I feel like it was at that moment
when you really realize that talking
to people about Science
is really exciting to me,
and I really find so much meaning in it.
So I really, I decided that I also wanted
to do communication aside
from just pure Physics, so yeah.
- Yeah and you mentioned,
it's kind of like the Oscars
and Yuri Milner who's
really the driving force
behind the Breakthrough Junior Challenge.
That was his whole intent,
which is we celebrate
people in music and movies,
but really there are people like changing
the frontiers of Science and mathematics
that are doing things that are...
I like movie stars too,
but that are doing things
that are gonna change humanity
and benefit humanity.
They needed to be awarded the same way.
And also young people who
can communicate Science,
when you communicate Science.
That's how I always think
about my job at Khan Academy.
I do still secretly hope
that I might be able to like create
some new math theorem
or find some new particle or something.
But I also like to think that,
by communicating the Science
that there's going to be folks
like y'all millions of them.
And one of y'all are going to figure out
how to travel at warp speed
or solve climate change or cure cancer.
And so I think that's the real power
of Science Communication,
which both of y'all are
already on a fast track,
maybe one final question for both of you,
what advice would you have for
a young person like yourself
a year or two or three years ago?
Who's like well yeah,
I think I could do it,
but gee, it's so hard,
a lot of your doubts
that y'all had maybe start with you,
Hillary, what advice would you have
for someone who is thinking about it,
or maybe is a little bit afraid
to throw their hat in the ring?
- Yeah so my first advice
would be to just not be afraid.
I always say this, and he said
this earlier, when you fail,
you don't really fail.
You only learn.
I have said that a number of times,
and I'm always surprised
at how much it resonates
with people, because I mean, we all feel
that way sometimes, right?
We feel like we've kind of failed,
but if you look at it from
a different perspective,
take it as a learning experience,
a learning opportunity,
then it won't feel too bad at all.
And then it would make you even braver
to pursue better opportunities
to enrich yourself,
to meet new people and
all of these things.
So definitely don't take
anything as a failure,
take it as a learning
experience. That's my advice.
- And what about you, Maryam?
- I mean, I found out about
the challenge five years ago
and I didn't think I
could get anywhere with it
because I was always like
intimidated by the other videos
and the other like older
teams and everything.
But if you're, if someone watching,
you're thinking about participating
in a Breakthrough Junior Challenge,
I just wanna let you know
you it doesn't take a lot.
I was working on like a
half a broken computer
and my friend was helping me edit
on his like, shattered iPad.
Like we don't have like
any professional video making abilities
or like software.
And like all the animations
in my video were made with Google slides.
It doesn't take a lot, so
you should at least try
because the focus is obviously
on the communication,
not necessarily your abilities.
And if you love Science,
want to share Science.
Then nothing can stop you.
- No well, that resonates a lot with me
because both of your videos
are like high-tech Pixar compared to mine.
So you get...
(laughing)
- I'm definitely on the lower
production end of things.
But you know, this is a real treat.
I look forward to seeing you both.
I hope everyone watching,
there was an amazing finalist.
I mean, both of y'all had a lot
of other strong competitors,
I think y'all were a
notch above everyone else,
but congratulations to
everyone who is a finalist.
And I've got to believe that even
the folks who didn't quite
get to where y'all are,
but got to the finalists that hopefully
the process of making
the videos means a lot.
Whenever someone applies
for a job, I'm like,
what have they made?
So, hopefully everyone uses
their videos as their calling cards
to show how they both can
understand difficult concepts,
but also communicate it.
And I just wanna thank
you both because even
though hopefully what the
Breakthrough Junior Challenge
is providing you is gonna
be a great foundation
for the rest of your life.
And it feels like y'all might
be the ones winning the prize.
I genuinely feel that it's society that's
going to win the prize
because it's going to
unlock your abilities
to do more for all of us.
So thank you so much
and keep communicating
and keep pushing the frontiers of Science.
Both Maryam and Hillary, thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- Well, thanks everyone for joining.
You know, I really
encourage you to look at,
we saw Maryam's video re-watch it,
it is actually probably
the best explanation
of quantum tunneling you can find.
I also encourage you to
watch Hillary's video,
probably the best explanation
of Relativity you can find.
And also look at the other
Breakthrough Junior Challenge
winners over the last several years,
and actually the finalist, a
lot of really great concepts.
I'm watching them with my kids,
it's probably the best
way to expose yourself
to some concepts in math
and Science that most folks think
are beyond them, but
really, really aren't.
So take a look at it and
thanks for joining today.
And I look forward to seeing...
I'm fighting the sun, the sun shows up
at around this time of day, in my closet,
but I look forward to seeing you
all at the next homeroom with Sal.
Thanks for joining us today.
And yes, we'll have the head
of Teach for America,
Elisa Villanueva Beard
to discuss on Wednesday, so see all there.